Hãy bỏ lưu cộng của mình của mình chút nào,
và như là nó có thể giảm ơn.
Nhưng mà nếu mà nó ở hãn lộn,
lời xây hò,
ở những cái vụ cận xúc hãi của mình này,
thì hãn nó là dưới hó,
thì mà nó có thể giảm chút xây hãn.
Và trong một cái này tìm tế mà,
thì nó có một giảm,
và xuất bởi vì tìm cáo,
và các người tìm là dưới hãn đối với ai như giảm lúc hó.
Họ chí, và các nhà tìm rồi hảy,
thì nó đồng xảm rất hói mà giảm ưu.
Nó.
Nhưng mà lại qua lại có chuyện lúc này,
là bất đổ sẵn có ra,
nhưng mà nó sẽ đi in cây ảy chủch,
trước là tụi đấy.
Là đi theo tụi không,
là đi theo cầu trị và khai,
có mới đo khó,
thì mình sẽ cây hó,
cho các gửi chi tế,
thì cái gì gà,
thì cái gì mà làm quân.
Hồi anh nghĩ thì anh,
lúc nghĩ mà,
nên đo cử của lướng,
hóc, cái quụng,
lướng, hói, cái quụng,
hói, hụng, hụng, hụng, hụng,
mấy giờ mình có tìm lửa sẵn cho các bạn,
thì các bạn có,
chỉ còn lửa mọi người,
là phố rất nhiều cái,
hay là mức thử,
hay là mọi người rất nhiều,
thì đây là những anh,
thì rất hổ thân quả,
và trong một cái chuyện lửa mọi thứ của chơi đối thạm.